oh it's not as long as you're gonna be
respectful and cool and do that I got it
we're [ __ ] best friends alright so go
ahead ask away what do you know okay I
do have a question it's a serious
question I'm wondering be really whoa
Michele gauntlet
dude I'll tell you about shoes in case
he gets lost in the forest
no what's weird is though it's even
though I have the beard and the longer I
was
[Music]
I want to say this - no no no dude this
real [ __ ] hair it's real what if I
just lay sees you aren't playing a
football guy are you playing that's not
dude I haven't wait I have good if
somebody was like if somebody was like
oh like you're the boy he's lost in the
forest and they saw the forest was like
my hair they be like but if they saw any
and Fox was like his hair to be like
[Music]
what
[ __ ] Hong Kong
[Applause]